[Music]
the boys crowned a new champion last
night giving blake bragging rights once
again and his number one fan was right
there to enjoy every moment and
overjoyed when Stefani celebrated team
Blake's win backstage but her three boys
three year old Apollo wasn't 100% into
it but just like mom and even their 72
year old grandpa gana Stefani both
zoomin Kingston had a blast poking fun
at Shelton's not so modest finale suit
jacket before he became the voices six
time coaching champ last night Blake was
definitely playing up that other big
title today winner Chloe who was
originally knocked off team Miley and
saved by Blake told us on a tee Facebook
live why he was the greatest coach alive
he kind of just celebrates each artist
for who they are any less them just do
their thing he kind of okay here you go
I don't really understand what you're
wearing or what your hair is so big but
I want you to just do your thing
nearly 11 million people watch the 23
year old rock singer from Tennessee
joined Billy Idol on the stage to belt
out his hit for her finale performance
blake hopes chloe can continue her
streak we're all dying to know what
you're gonna come up with
including your old double chin coach
sitting here
[Music]
you